[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
March 30th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
pay transparency laws have been in place
in several areas of the country for a
few years and have cast a spotlight on
things like workers salaries and listed
pay ranges for open positions wsja
contributor Courtney venepal joins us to
discuss Recent research on how the laws
are being received by workers hey
Courtney thank you for being with us
thanks for having me
So Courtney what kinds of concerns have
these new pay transparency laws raised
so I think there is a prevailing fear
among a lot of Human Resources
Executives and employers that sharing
too much information about pay can cause
workers to become demotivated and maybe
look for the exit door look for a higher
paying job I think a lot of people have
been in that scenario before they find
out that they're making less than their
co-workers at a similar level and it can
be very discouraging so I think that is
the prevailing fear among a lot of
employers right now so let's talk about
some recent studies that focused on paid
transparency and how it's being received
by employees you went through research
from several universities about paid
transparency among University workers
what stood out to you yeah so pay
transparency while it's just coming to a
lot of companies it has been the case
that academics at public universities
know their peer salaries for a number of
years now that's because of transparency
efforts by state agencies and news
organizations so a recent paper looked
at this in the context of Academia and
they tracked how paid transparency
affected productivity among academics in
eight different states after paid
transparency took effect so they
actually found that among these
academics there was no discernible dip
in productivity in the years after paid
transparency took effect in these states
if anything it's bird them to work
harder this was actually the case among
academics who found out that they were
making more than their peers performing
at similar levels they for example
produced seven percent more articles in
the years after salary transparency was
revealed so that was a sort of
surprising counter-intuitive finding of
this study and I think what it says is
that at least in the context of Academia
there was no discernible dip in
productivity as academics found out more
information about their peers salaries
so the academics were okay with their
being pay and Equity that actually
wasn't the case so there was one
important exception to the overall
findings here and that was when paid
transparency revealed high levels of
inequity within an institution or
Department meaning that there were big
pay disparities among workers performing
at similar levels then overall
productivity actually decreased and the
researcher I spoke with thinks that that
was because these workers realized they
were operating in an environment that
wasn't fair so whether they were being
overpaid or underpaid it caused them to
lose motivation all right so back to the
us since pay transparency laws went into
effect we've gotten a good picture of
things like pay ranges for posted jobs
has that translated into Happy employees
we're not sure I guess is the short
answer one study that I looked at from a
number of different researchers one
researcher is based at UCLA it's a model
which suggests that workers who are
overconfident in their abilities so they
assume that they will make more than
most of their peers once it's revealed
that they're actually making in line
with what their peers make they become
dissatisfied and unhappy I will say that
this study also found that employers
don't have to reveal the granular
details of their compensation structure
to motivate workers a separate study
that was led in part with this
researcher at UCLA that I spoke to found
that students who participated in a
computer game and were paid for that
tried harder when they found out what
their peers earned and they didn't have
to find out what each individual peer
earned to work harder they just had to
know what the average peer was earning
and it would motivate them to work
harder so I think that suggests that
employers don't have to necessarily
reveal the Nitty Gritty details of their
pay structure to see these motivating
effects what do all these studies mean
for human resources departments across
the business world yeah so I think a lot
of HR departments are grappling with how
much information they should be sharing
with employees the laws that have taken
effect obviously a lot of times only
require them to just share salary ranges
but there is some evidence coming out of
these studies I think that sharing
information for how employees can
progress within an organization and what
they need to do to get to a certain
level can actually be motivating but I
think HR departments really have to
think about how they want to reveal that
information and they have to think about
maybe training their managers to have
those conversations because they can be
tricky conversations to have the HR
Executives who I spoke to that are
putting resources behind this have
attested that it has been motivating and
even if employees are not necessarily
happy with what paid transparency
reveals it opens the door for more
candid Frank discussions about what they
can do to advance in their career and
Advance at that organization you know
these paid transparency laws have
resulted in a windfall of information
for people in States in areas that have
these laws in effect
but for people in parts of the country
where paid transparency laws are not in
effect what sort of resources do they
have to find out information about
salaries and salary ranges
so I think the effect of the paid
transparency laws is it's just creating
a domino effect for a lot of employers
even if they are not posting the
salaries for their positions themselves
there are a lot of other organizations
now that will post at least estimates of
the salaries so indeed.com for example
is a hiring job site where you'll often
see estimates of salaries for positions
even if it's not at an organization that
has made those salaries transparent yet
and you also have a lot of new
compensation companies that are working
to use that data and give prospective
employees a lot more information than
they would have had in previous years
all right that's Wall Street Journal
contributor Courtney vanopal with us
Courtney thank you very much for being
with us on the show thanks for having me
and that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you